all right so today we're talking about
decentralized data and how we take this
centralized data and apply machine
learning but also apply other such
computations right thank analytics thing
you know any any kind of competition
that that can benefit from from
decentralized data right so so for so
the talk today so it's a tutorial to
just to start off we have on the
tensorflow federated website I'll show
you the link in a second we have these
tutorials and this is an expert this is
basically that dive into that same
tutorial the Tostitos i'll use google
collab notebooks so you should be able
to run them yourself what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna run to the motivation of of
decentralized data drink we're going to
further their learning then we're going
to talk about the more general topic of
federated computations which is which is
the intuition that we came up with as we
started working with federated learning
and then finally with even the key part
here is to talk about tensorflow
federated which is our open source
effort that we we want everyone to come
participate you want to build this the
community and you know enable more and
more use cases for privacy-preserving
computations and this general aspiration
is like it's it's for you know you know
privacy being central to computations
right so like today the world is like
privacy has become a key deliverable for
any app developer or any software right
and potata learning is one of those
techniques that can offer utility of a
software without compromising on privacy
so like the existing
existing model of app-like xt model used
as centralized servers where models
learn in essential a server we want to
break away from the pattern and come up
with this new way of computing computing
computation right so all right so like I
said let's start talking about
decentralized data all right so does it
actually even make sense to have this
centralized data can data actually live
at the edge so most of the data so today
like smartphones are ubiquitous sensors
are Paraiba q this right so IOT is
taking off or already has taken off
maybe right so there is there is like
this plethora of data that is out there
right data resident on devices at rest
and so we can leverage devices that are
on the edge and learn from them pretty
easily right so if you if you think
about models or you know just gel coat
of learning you can you can actually
learn a lot on device itself you will
get much improved latency if you if you
run learning on a device device you
don't have to go back and forth to some
centralized location it works offline
because you know their data caps and
whatnot so it can work offline
definitely saves battery because one of
the most battery draining activities is
actually connecting often on on two
networks privacy advantages which is our
key central point here like to keep to
do not send data off my device right the
device is something that I own and
that's my domain right the moment it
leaves that leaves my device the owner's
device the owner has lost control of the
data right so if that's the premise then
this is this is huge so great so so you
actually have the tooling to learn on
on device and you have all these
advantages that your outlined of
learning in a device so so that that's
fantastic right but is it really
fantastic no right so basically because
how do you know how you're doing right
if you want to device I mean how do you
analyze how do you how do you learn
about your learning right if learning is
the problem that you resolve and there
is definitely patterns that you could
learn if you know if a person in person
B use the same application there is poly
stem learning to be shared between their
two experiences right and so so there's
fundamental things that are missing here
right so if you just create a lot of
different silos if you're just learning
on a device which can be bridged if
there was some way to kind of
collaborate across devices right so in
comes basically the idea of centralized
learning rate going way back a step and
going into centralized learning so think
about this particular model right so
there is data on the client the client
makes a request the model learning is
happening at the server the model is at
the server so basically the data is on
the client the model is the server and
the request comes in to the server the
learning happens on the on the server
itself is centralized learning and then
basically the data asks a question the
prediction goes back and the client
gives feedback so this is okay this is
back to that that model where the data
is is on the client but they some I want
to live is leaking to the server so
learning is on a server right so so
you're going going back and forth but
one thing that we can get out of this
centralized learning is like if there is
in one place then it's easy to learn
that much we can infer right but let's
see if we can make this better
I think so but centralization has it's
clear disadvantages right I think we
talked about this briefly we now
introduce latency if you're offline then
just becomes impossible to learn and
then actually there's actually cost
involved not just you know privacy
concerns but there is actual costs
involved in learning on the under on the
server data caps this battery life I
talked about all these things just a
recap of the same thing so now the key
question can we learn without collecting
data and so basically it comes to
learning so so we sort of established at
this point that
yeah there's decentralized data on
devices learning in this on the server
like in a centralized location is
something that we have explored that has
clear disadvantages learning on the
device itself has advantages but then
you don't share learning so we have to
come up with some model that where data
never leaves the device the other
seasonal device privacy is protected and
you'll learn collaboratively so in comes
federated learning which is essentially
machine learning on decentralized data
that's like roughly what we're learning
is right so if I read from the slide
says basically enable edge devices do
state-of-the-art machine learning
without centralizing data and obviously
if you centralized data it's already one
step in the direction of privacy it's
not everything but it's one step in the
direction of privacy so privacy is by
design in this in the in the schema in
the in this technology
privacy's by default because data never
leaves the leaves the device right
so we can do all the training on the
device which is established it's
something we can do I think I'll skip
over this we already talked about these
two little data pliant other clients are
in contributing so so this is one
alternative that people have tried right
so you pre train a model on the server
right with some proxy data that you farm
off of either you generate that data or
you farm it off of devices some which is
also sort of a gray area right how do
you get those that proxy data right you
have to have some intuition about real
data and there is privacy compromised
right there but let's say if I hand wave
on that let's see if you have access to
some proxy data then you can train the
model in the cloud or in some remote
location in a server and then once you
have trained that model then you can
push that P 10 model and now the device
can take from there but still there is
no collaboration right so it's basically
one centralized model P trained model
then that the devices improve on but
there is no feedback mechanism there is
no collaboration
so let's just see how predator learning
works right so the initial model is
decided by the engineer who who's the
model engineer right so the decider the
initial model is and basically for the
initial model it can be very simple
right so I mean even random in the
initialization is sufficient it's what
we found out and if you have proxy data
like like in the previous slide you can
train or approximate and that becomes
you initial model so that that technique
doesn't change then the client also once
once it goes to the client the client
trains on on that data and then you get
the locally trained model and then the
local train model and just the model
rate the model update not the data
itself the locally train model makes it
back to the server right so and here is
basically the thing that has been other
alluding to all this while it keep the
raw data local right and so the data
never leave the device it's in the
device the cloud learns nothing about
the data the raw data itself right the
onus of now maintaining that data or you
know making making privacy's making the
data secure is definitely on the app
itself right it has to expire the data
at on a timely fashion and it has to
enter keep it at rest so that it doesn't
leak right so but the the learning
protocol is completely agnostic to what
data there was it doesn't need the data
and so it's completely out of the
picture so that's that's sort of the
privacy technology that is enabled with
this so nothing about like a whole
cohort of clients right it's a bunch of
clients out there they're all doing the
same thing and you are basically all
these devices are learning and they're
all sitting the updates back roughly at
the same time
here is the key thing here is sort of
magic which is all these models come in
and then we do federated model averaging
it's essentially jumping the machine
learning here a little bit if the
learning on these devices they did so
basically they did some gradient descent
assuming that's optimizes they used so
basically those many steps are averaged
right so we call this federated model
averaging and then basically we get a
combined model it's provable that this
combined model actually is it's
combinatorial result of all the
different model objects that came from
the from the clients so then this
combined model is it's something that
comes to the server there are some
additional things that I'm not mentioned
here this can actually be so like I
mentioned in the beginning that the data
obviously never leaves the device but
but it's model updates the only thing
comes so a question that you may ask is
like now you see the model updates can
we make some so if you see model updates
over time can you make some sense of the
data right that'll be leaking privacy
the question is yeah maybe right so two
things there one is these devices are
presumably selected at random right
there is no way to and if I which update
came from which device that's that's a
key point here right so and even if
there was a curious but not malicious
entity that were looking at these
updates and trying to make sense of them
there are other technologies which I'm
not going to go into today
one thing called secure aggregation that
we have published paper on which can
potentially even word of that so we
introduced some noise that noise cancels
out but basically there are technologies
that can that we can we can use
to reduce the probability that that you
can infer something about the raw data
from the models themselves model empties
themselves yeah so one so federated
model averaging is I'd round the time to
this is paper you're welcome to you I
really encourage people to read the
paper that was published a few years
back but as just an intuition basically
the way it works is it's a data weighted
average of the model updates so all
these model of this comes and so it's a
data weighted average of that updated
models and that sort of gives you the
combined combined model yeah good
question so the question is can you have
a cohort of malicious clients that
collaborate amongst themselves and and
basically poison their learning
potentially yes but the the main thing
is that the number needs to be very high
for of that the size of that population
has to be significantly high because I
maybe I didn't mention this but the
server is the one that's selecting which
clients participate in this right so if
the if the so so basically what are the
odds that if you have a small pop if you
have a population of a million devices
then you have a smaller size of you know
some hundreds of devices that are
interest that are selected by server and
the probability that you will select one
from that cohort of collaborating
clients is fairly low but theoretically
is possible
so yeah so the model comes in and then
combined model goes back out to again
back up so it's iterative process it
goes back out to a set of clients and
like I say this client has selected a
random based on some heuristics and so
basically the chances that the same clan
gets picked up over and over again is
significantly low unless the publisher
it's depending on the population size if
the if the number of clients is closer
to the number of clients you need the to
compute then Clancy we get repeated
often but essentially this happens in a
repetitive fashion now so the combined
one will come seen it goes back out to a
set of devices the device is learned and
it sends back in and so on so forth so
so that goes on and and basically like
any other machine learning you can also
you will also evaluate your your
learning over time and essentially at
some point you will find that your your
convergence is what you what you need
and at that point you have a proper
model that that you can now work with
right so is that idea let me just finish
this
yeah yeah
so typically this is for Karis models is
but there is I think this can be
extended to any kind of model per se I
mean that the technology itself is not
specific to the kind of models right but
when I talk about in several federated
you'll see that I'll mention that in a
recording will be catered to our skyress
models but it can be easily adjusted to
other kinds of models
sorry yes yes yes yes if it doesn't even
make sense right right so this is a
quick shout out to the to the Google
mobile keyboard effort where essentially
this has been I can't say proven but
this is this is work so there's you know
this is the next word completion is that
the paper out there which actually works
without any collection of data as does
keyboard query suggestions right yes
yeah yeah so you can I you can start
with pre-trained data or you can
basically start with very very initial
state right like even a random thing
would work because since the the initial
model really is it will take you longer
to converge potentially right if each of
the random random weights yes this is
the point so I that's the more sort of
yeah so the client resources that are
precious so you would want clients to do
less and I'll mention that briefly in
the next few slides so typically what
what people do is they run simulations
so you can you can take your model and
like I said you can take proxy data and
you can actually have potentially
machines in the in a cloud or something
that that pretends to be clients right
so you can you can think of a machine
and you spin up multiple threads and
each thread becomes a client or
something of that sort some setup like
that and you run training and so before
you go out in the wild you already have
a pre trained model that's typically the
flow but I'm just thinking you should be
able to do even with random yeah so now
the intuition is now once we once people
started working with ready to learning a
bit the thing is like they're
fundamentally the protocol itself is not
specifically you know connected to
learning right it's it's it's a it's a
it's a general process of technology
that can be used for analytics for
example right so if you have do want to
do privacy-preserving analytics you
could I think right so cool so let's
think about federated competition then
which is just extension like you
mentioned from federated learning and it
you can think of its analogy it's like
privacy-preserving it's like a map it's
like Map Reduce but built on top of
decentralized data and privacy right so
so as you go along so if you remember so
we talked about federated model
averaging that was one thing as you go
along talking about faded computation
it's it's a more broader you know non
machine learning subject when you talk
about this then basically we'll see how
privacy is addressed at a very ground
level right so this is repetition of
what I already talked about so let's say
you have a bunch of clients but this is
more simple at this point there's no
models nothing and let's say each device
has its own data so in this particular
case let's say these are sensors or
devices that keeps track of temperatures
of a day right so they all have this
data on the devices and and the data is
local obviously the same
privacy-preserving technology so now our
job is to find what's the average
maximum temperature experienced by the
fleet of devices right let's say that's
the problem right so we're gonna find
out on the server I mean obviously
server and by the way I one thing once
you mention is when I keep on saying
server it's just an entity right it
doesn't have to be really a server in
the cloud per se right it potentially
could be a connected device that's
connected all the time right so it's
just the notion of an entity okay so how
do you get them at average maximum
temperature right so okay this is a kind
of busy slide bunch of things came in
right so let's say so scenario is let's
say we want to find out not just the
average but a little bit more right
let's say we're to find out how much so
what's the fraction of devices with the
reading that is
larger than a threshold temperature
right that's it it's a more realistic
example rate instead of just computing
average across random devices we're
going to find out what fraction of
devices explain the temperature more
than 70 finite something like that right
so the way it works is so the if you
remember the persona of the model
engineer in this case it's not a model
anymore but it's the person of an
engineer who actually controls this
experiment they are they're determining
the in one of the inputs to the to the
whole validity computation which is that
input of the threshold which is 75 a
night and we are interested in the
output which is the fraction of sensors
readings greater than the threshold
right so what happens first so first
thing that will happen is that threshold
much like the model in the in the
federated learning case will get
broadcast to all the devices right so
you're introduced the notion of the
input that comes from the engineer so
that's the input we obviously have the
output and now this one this fan out of
information to all the devices there's
also the act of actually selecting those
devices that I glossed over but I did
mention that devices are selected at
random right so there's these some
devices get selected and then this
threshold goes out to those devices
right so now so each device computes so
it has the readings like I mentioned so
in the first slide right so that each
device has these own reading the data
never leaves so it basically just
computes that one simple calculation
which is is my temperature
large of my max temperature rather is
that is my max temperature more or less
than the threshold that I got from the
server right so that's the simple
calculation right let's say returns a
boolean or one or zero back okay
these values then come back and they can
be aggregated using an aggregation
operator so we talked about federated
model averaging more general-purpose
things operate didn't mean right so
basically this is a simple aggregation
technique here but think of the
federated mean as the whole process of
this multiple devices sending this one
number back or one result back one data
type back one value back and then the
server actually running these
aggregations wearing this federated beam
which is on all the different and
outputs that came from the devices and
then coming up with a number right
so that whole computation that whole
operation is what we're calling
federated mean so an important thing I
mention is these things are these green
arrows are potentially happening over a
so basically it's it's not happening
instantly right so there's a time window
is sliding we know where these things
are coming in and then the server is
aggregating this right so the whole
operation is very little mean
yeah so this is I'm calling it
technology number three but it's
essentially an extension on that world
period model averaging thing we talked
about because it's still an aggregation
that is happening at a federated scale
and basically combining reports on these
multiple devices and coming up with an
answer
so this is kind of important here so try
to see if we can extract them privacy
principles that that have come up with
with what you learned about ready to
learning and unfitted competition can we
establish some privacy principles so the
sort of and and we're also looking at it
from person as right so so there is a
server there's the device there is
potentially the man in the middle and
there's an engineer who's access to this
data right so one first privacy
principle that we're establishing here
is that you can only access the combined
device reports right you cannot see
individual device supports even if you
cannot identify the device if you cannot
connect the device of the device reports
what you have access to is just a
combined device reports because because
that is the only thing that that the
server is interested so all the reports
comes in you have merged them and then
you get one value and one value is the
is the thing that you're that you're
persisting right so so anyone from the
outside who's access to the to the
server server storage has only access to
that all that aggregate and nothing else
none of the raw data this is the other
thing right so this is a privacy
principle number two is the per device
reports are not useful right because
once you compute the average or failure
I didn't mean we can just throw that
away
so who should never persist any other
per device reports they don't necessary
and so that's the privacy principle
number two we can what we need to what
you collect is just it's just ephemeral
we just need it for the duration of the
computation of the favor to me and not
longer yeah there's a third privacy
principle which is focused collection
right we just returned that one value
which is the one or zero indicate
whether the max temperatures were higher
than the threshold or not and that's the
only thing so it's focused collection
devices only report the very minimum
that is needed right so that's other
privacy busily establishing that devices
only report what the very minimum of
what is needed we don't store anything
on the server the
like you know what comes from the
reports of the device are never stored
and finally the only thing we stored is
the aggregate all right and finally like
I mentioned infrared learning this is
repeatedly break so so it's iterative
process you you can improve this pardon
my arrows you can improve this what you
would you know about your competition by
repeating it because the key thing here
is you are selecting different devices
every term they say the same thing
applied for more federated learning as
well because you the fact that you are
selecting potentially different set of
devices every single time gets you to
learn more in this case you will compute
a more accurate fraction of sensors with
readings as you pick more and more
devices it is it is it is it should be
guaranteed right yes so yes so I think
it'll be more clear when I talk about
tensile for federated but so it's a
principle right so design principle
right so if I'm Bill so if somebody
builds a malicious solution why they
don't adhere to that principle then then
sure yeah that's that so in that aspect
is a matter of trust right what we're
suggesting is if you if you somebody
builds a framework and several federated
will internalize these principles right
and it's provable like I mean so you can
see the code and and that that this
device supports are not persisted
anywhere right so if it's FML you mean
it's easy to check that it's ephemeral
right these privacy principles are easy
to inspect and find out right if it's a
closed source project then you have less
visibility into what really is happening
right so it's a principle right so the
design principle is either adhere to or
not adhere to right the only way to
prove that Israel to
by allowing court inspection and and
binary at the station
I guess alright yeah
so now I think it what's important here
is these are pull this learning and
faded competitions are areas of active
research we are in so privacy is central
to this things and like I mentioned
right some of the questions you asked
right I mean everyone asked the same
questions right we privacy is something
that you can never sort of check box and
say like oh this is this is completely
foolproof
there are exploits that that we need to
be aware of and and and keep on
iterating to make these things better
and and so this extension that if you
look at the extension the first one is
differential privacy which is another
sort of pillar that yeah so yeah so
that's another pillar that we want to
what we want to internalize then and and
Billie to tensorflow federated which I'm
going to talk to talk about in a second
and and and then there is additional
things like compression and quantization
that we will not not cover today
all right so tensorflow federated this
is the key part of the talk today so
with the introduction Slade so let's
jump you tensorflow federated the thing
to mention here is I put a QR code there
and that's a link if you want
now you can potentially jump into
because I'm going to go pretty fast over
the code that we're going to show you're
welcome to go there and start the
tutorials and there's a collab which is
I would suggest the best way to run that
you
and is also linked to the to the github
repo for the for the tensile failure to
code I really encourage everyone to go
take a look you know read the code file
bugs and contribute right because the so
we we pretty strongly feel that their
myriad of use cases that we do not know
of and we maybe never know off right so
this project can be best built as a
community effort because we just have
scratch the surface we have some
building blocks that we've identified
and we have tried to put those building
blocks together and we continue in doing
that but I think this project will
definitely its stands to benefit
immensely from being open source and and
and that's why so yeah so tensorflow
org slash federated and there's a link
to the github repo and and tutorials and
introduction and the API is and
everything alright so as you run to
testable federated I'm gonna quickly
give an introduction and then we're
gonna look at first the FL API which is
a federated learning API and see some
code examples and then then I'm gonna
talk about the FC API talk about some
core concepts of a federated computation
API which and I'm gonna look back at the
at the example that we just saw and look
at the code examples and maybe I'll
mention tip actually I think I'm
mentioning at one tip but a tip or two
hey they can talk about stuff so and
like I mentioned that several facilities
open source framework for machine
learning and other competitions on
decentralized data pretty straight for
at this point I think hopefully I've
been able to communicate that part that
it's yeah you should be able to do other
computations as well sorry
so that's a github link if somebody
wants to go look at the code while I'm
explaining these things like you
mentioned it's being developed in the
public it's absolutely open to
contributions
things are changing really fast I mean
we're we are adding features to ten
Sybilla federated really really quickly
so yeah please join us in any way I
really encourage to read the code read
some of the you know design principles
but and definitely run the tutorials so
why so so what's a value prop 48 tff
right so and dff as an open framework
sorry I'm gonna use tff as a placeholder
for tensorflow federated long name the
first thing that we want to enable is so
basically enable this for researchers
right so this should be something easy
you know to get a good idea about a
technique that is let's say you've made
a model or in the case of competition a
competition does it really make sense
right so if you have some proxy data so
you can quickly run this using
tensorflow federated you can put
something together real quickly and then
run it and see if it works so you can
focus on the actual problem and the
infrastructure to run things in a
federated fashion is something that PFF
can do for you so essentially separation
of concerns the the second thing is yeah
develop together so you can reuse
components so essentially you can
combine either whether it's a it's it's
something part of the framework that
you're combining or you know if you're
collaborating in research you're
combining your own code but basically
you can develop faster and eventually
you poorly create an ecosystem and we
definitely hope that we can we can as a
community can create an ecosystem which
enables new applications new patterns
and definitely new deployment
environments so this is a very important
point and wanted to call out is it's
absolutely architecture agnostic it does
not care what machine is running on it
actually does not care what device it's
running on its what tff compiles into is
a representation of what that federated
competition looks in case of federated
computation is federated learning which
is a special case of edited computation
then then that but since it's it's
essentially a serialized representation
of what that competition looks looks
like technically you should be able to
expand it to any sort of deployment
environment right so the devices could
be any kind of devices right so you have
to probably write like you know we have
to probably write adapters or whatnot to
make it run on a specific kind of
platform but tensorflow doesn't restrict
you from doing that all right yeah so
like I mentioned so right now we support
a local simulation runtime so you can
basically whether if you use a code lab
or even if you you know write the code
on your own machine we support a local
simulation runtime but yeah we can
support other deployment environments as
time comes and there is the link to the
tutorials I think this link takes you to
the tensile profile arc federated and
then there's option for tutorials where
you can go and look at the tutorials
yeah so you can focus I think the main
key point here is that there is since
the open source project there is
advantage of having shared learning and
so you know pain points will give me
as you know we built federated learning
systems we will address this and as like
10 super would be this one effort where
do you address this and hopefully
transfer from federated be that one
effort where we address those and
mitigate those pinpoints yeah
so here the important point I want to
mention is that this tension between
order of construction and execution so
typically you know there's like when you
build your computation and when you
execute it there is there is certain
orderly you want to this is certain
order then you have to follow and that's
or there is a it's not a prescribed
order but there's a typical order that
you you followed you do these things and
there is a bit of tension there right so
that pain point is is address by tff
because since its kind of pluggable so
essentially you you do you're you're you
when you run your tensor flow plan or
sit in the tensor flow computation you
basically what you're doing like I say
this is a less representation of what
your competition looks like what happens
on a device what happens in a server how
do they communicate back in the protocol
between the server end clients so you
basically have you basically represent
that and in some say lies format and
basically you're doing it using Python
code so you're writing a block of Python
code and what it does it it gives you
the sales representation right now what
happens actually in your competition or
if in case of edited learning what
what's that what were the actual model
parameters and everything is outside of
outside the tff primo right so that
tension is addressed and I think that
the first point is also similar thing so
you're interleaving different types of
logic right so it's and we'll see that
in a second
so what's in the box right so when you
when you get in simplified what do you
get so you get for the FL party you get
implementation of federated training and
evaluation I may have not talked already
evaluated but I mean I think evaluation
is the important step in learning which
is essentially when you run your models
on on test data and see how you're doing
so we get implementations of federated
training and an evaluation it's out of
the box and obviously you can you can
use like you mentioned any existing ten
supermodels or tens little data it can
be can be used to run can you can
basically federal eight you know
existing ten supermodel or data and run
run and F along them using tff for
federated core it allows for expressing
new federated algorithm straight so I we
saw an example of a simple averaging
across devices you can do more complex
ones I guess right and it offers a local
runtime for simulations which is what I
mentioned and again this is a community
project there multiple ways to get
involved you can apply FL in tf2
existing models which is which is what I
was talking about a second back for ml
dev you can very easily federate your
model and see if that makes it better
right if your FL researchers right you
can try a new federated algorithms if
there are extensions that you think are
not existent and there'll be lots of
those you can actually go contribute you
can add those and then and you know and
enable those if your system researchers
then you would be more focused on on FC
api's and and essentially you can do
oops better
me ii say yeah so you can you can target
newer platforms or or build new varied
competition structures but give me one
second power and that's the link to the
Sophie if you hit that QR code I think
you'll go to the tutorial learning API
so yeah so this so we're gonna follow
the the first tutorial which is the
image classification tutorial for FL we
if you are if you have familiar with the
M nest data set that's a lot of
experimentation is based on so that's
what that's the data that we use it's a
data set that's provided by tensorflow
as well as tensorflow federated and and
that's the tutorial we're gonna run
parts of the tutorial today so if you go
to that link that I just gave you you
should be able to there we they'll be
linked to see the source and github you
can read the code or you can run that
tutorial on collab alright so first
things first so if you learn predatory
learning on using tff the first thing
you would want to do is going to prepare
your federated data sets for training so
we also tff like I mentioned supply some
of these data data sets we so the
Emily's database that data set you know
that that that is there that is supplied
by tensorflow bear tensorflow
tff actually supplies that same data
sets in a federated format right so it's
ready to sort of use and I'll show you
in a second
right and there's a project called leaf
that actually took some of these
datasets and and made made them
palatable for federated learning all
right so here is you know a simple block
of code that that shows how you can load
data sets tff data sets and and you can
let you know try to play around with it
a little bit so essentially that
facility data set M NIST is the MDS data
set that is that is supplied by tff and
essentially you call load data on on
this and that gives you a pair of train
data and test data right and if you look
at the following lines you'd see that
you know you can the change it actually
has something called client ID so it's
already shorted in a certain number of
clients right and you can then think you
can actually move these things around
right so it's it's a standard tensorflow
data set that you can you can actually
move around so but I'm making some
assumptions about general awareness over
tensorflow if there is something that
doesn't make sense please stop me and
ask me the question right so okay so
yeah so we have loaded that example data
set and then essentially we we are
basically creating a data set for a
specific client right and the idea here
is to show that you know it's like if
you if we access a particular shard and
get a data set for a particular shard
then what I'm doing is a since this is a
this is Emily's database so I'm using
the PI plot library here to essentially
see you know you can you can potentially
run this code and it will show you the
actual
like that the picture of the of the
economy instead of the pixel that that
is in the data set right so the data set
itself has has two features one is the
label which is basically the name of the
digit and the other is the I think it's
a 28 by 28 image of that digit
handwritten digit yeah I think I missed
the eminence database I is essentially
that it's it's a it's a set of
handwritten digits that are labeled
that's the training data so so yeah one
part that pixels is essentially the pic
the the image of the hundred digit and
then this other one is I think it's
called label which is ten which is
actually the digit itself and by the way
this is all this code is from the
tutorial itself so yeah so I already
mentioned this so this this this
ready-made helper function create TF
data set for client and once you pass
the client ID creates an example data
set for the specific client here is what
something is something interesting right
once we have that data set we might want
to you can use like normal Python
functions to actually enhance the data
set and make it a little bit more
palatable for using you know using it
for your experimentation this is just an
example from the tutorial this is not
the canonical way to do this I'm just
trying to highlight that you can take
the data set you can you can you know
you can repeat that and you can actually
map it like in this particular case if
you see roughly what the mapping is
doing is it's it's takes that pixels and
and calls it X and and I think it takes
the label and calls it Y and think
that's to to make it acceptable for
Karis models but roughly that's what
it's doing and and then just shuffle it
around and then we create bad sizes
because this is something in training
you typically want mini batches of data
and so essentially this is this is P I
just wanted to highlight that you can
get P process your data
with standard Python code read you don't
have to do anything special it's yeah
right so so once you have once you have
written a pre-processing of data then
essentially what you can do is you can
run the same pre-processing for for
every single client right so what are
you doing here is just taking the
initial client data and and and and we
get the client IDs this both will soon
come from the training data and we we
essentially run this through that pre
process that you had in the previous
slide and we that gives us very early
data that we can now use for for for
training one obvious thing here is the
data set comes with a certain number of
client shard sites I do not exactly
remember how many shards but some number
of client IDs but you can if you want to
use more clients you can shuffle and
repeat and/or distribute that the data
in and you know in any way you want the
whole idea is basically it comes in the
data set and it's you can use standard
Python functions to redistribute the
data to change the data transform it
whatever you wanna do including like TF
you can use tensorflow transforms on
those alright so once we have the data
now we want to run a model I'm using a
chaos model and you suggest you use
chaos models because that's emerging as
a standard and but fundamentally yeah I
mean other models can also be use but
what we suggest that we use chaos
all right so so we take the train data
that's in the that's really just created
in the previous step and here we use a
standard helper function from Charis
model and that's becomes a model
function and then we basically our
training process is it's basically take
the model function which is the ellipsis
up there a model function is something
that that is beyond 10 self-fulfilled
the idea to show the previous slide was
that you know the model itself is
something that tensorflow doesn't care
about it's just wrapping federated
learning around existing model right so
you can use the helper function that
that that essentially builds the
training process and then there is two
important steps that happen so this is
this is I think it's call it the
iterative process essentially it has two
methods two properties basically two
methods that you can call is one is
initialize which is the start so if you
remember the federated learning slide I
talked about the first time when the
when the model goes out to all the
clients and the clients are ready to
train so that is essentially that step
so it it that state goes out and then
and and so the first time and so it gets
initialized and then we start the
iterative process where well you know so
let's say in this particular case we are
running in five times and and basically
the training is happening five times the
the whole notion of clients and and how
many clients there are this has already
been taking so here we don't talk about
we're running this as if it's it's a
single process right there is the whole
thing about data going out to clients
clients running training reporting back
aggregating and then the next thing
that's all abstracted out at this point
rate so
so when you call three that the that the
Train implementation actually
encompasses all that right so when you
do train next a whole set of computation
happens all that happens so when you
call next
the most recent updated model combined
model goes out to clients clients run
with their data on those models report
back and then new combined model is
generated right which is state yeah so
that whole thing happens and and train
dot next simply takes care of that right
and the the intuition here is like you
have a server model that one step is
doing a server model it takes federated
data so so all the data distributed
across clients and it generates a
service state and it generates metrics
so I think I didn't mention metrics
until now so metrics are important right
so you want to see how your training is
progressing right so so for every round
regenerate matrix but these metrics are
not per client but this is matrix a
combined metrics
yeah so this is another important point
is like we're running it like this this
iterative process that I mentioned
earlier in the in the slides so this
iteration this is happening to these
five iterations happening we call this
as rounds so every time a server pushes
a combined model out to the clients the
clients runs it on local data reports
those models back updated models back to
the model updates to the server the
server combines and gets a new combined
model along with metrics this whole
process is a round and that is
essentially that train dot next and we
are running through it five times here
so that iterative process yeah and this
is how evaluations are done you can do
it after every round or you can do it
after certain number of rounds that
there's no control tensile doesn't
dictate anything that's but essentially
when you evaluate basically what you're
doing is you're running it on on on the
test data right there yeah and basically
you're taking that model so evaluation
models are not the same as train models
I'm not gonna run detail about that but
basically it doesn't need all that a
training trainable model needs its
trainable model is the is the way it's
represented in tensile for a federated
internally so evaluation functions this
this helper function believe a federated
evaluation you can say it returns a
simpler model that you can use for
evaluations that you run on test data
get the metrics and and that's that
process goes on and so essentially at
some point those metrics will determine
what you want to do next
does it make sense over
all right moving on to federated core
so that's the qr-code federated core but
if you're already there it should be
pretty obvious there are tutorials in
this a continuation yeah so we're just
gonna go there to tutorials on the on
the site the first one is a basic FC API
tutorial and and the next one has a
little bit more where you actually go to
failure to the averaging in detail I'm
not gonna go through that today but all
right same same stuff links to run it in
collab we can go look at the source so
quickly go through what FC API is yeah
so it's a it's a language like I
mentioned for defining federated
computations it's strongly typed that's
that's really important we'll see how
its functional and it has TF concepts
and it also builds on distributed
communications the first class concept
right so essentially that is the fact of
the act of sorry sending out data like
you know in the example that we saw
about a temperature one there was the
threshold temperature that was getting
sent from the server out to all the
devices and that that communication that
broadcast is an example of disputed
communication that's a first class
concept it's a Python API and once again
so right now the only runtime the new
support is a simulation environment in a
local machine but fundamentally the
architecture is such that extending it
to other deployment environments is is
very feasible alright so it's kind of a
recap but what if so this notion of
credit and value so if you remember from
the FC
slides we talked about temperatures in
clients so if you take the same same
example then basically we introduce this
first class concept of federated values
now in the NT ffs right so it's a local
item of their type float 32 let's say
it's a sense reading could be mortal way
too but in this case it's a sense of
reading let's say so that's the notion
of a federated value so you know
basically it's offensive off of this
that float32 value being in all the
different all clients it's a multi set
the key thing here is there's a value
which is like the multi set of values
and this this also has other thing
called placement I'm going to talk to
talk about that in a bit but this is the
kind of canonical tff representation
so this braces mean it's a multi set so
it's it's it's number of values not the
same values different values and it's at
something called clients clients is the
literal placement but when I talk about
placement I'm gonna explain what clients
really is let's talk to the server in
the mix right now if you remember the
example we tried to find out so
basically the server has the the problem
was to find the none of the fraction of
devices that had a temperature higher
than a particular threshold right so oh
yeah so whether is whether is that
problem threshold or if you want to find
the average of temperature across
clients the key thing here is that there
is one value at the server that that we
aren't so when you're building this
computation we know that you have
represent that value and
right and that's written as that you
know float32 ad server now this server
becomes another placement literal right
so we talked about placement so so what
we have here is two Frederator types one
is a type that is you know a multi set
of floats at clients clients being this
thing called placements and and then
another value singular value float32 add
the server server being this other
placement right so what are placements
right so placements are essentially
groups of participants or cohorts in
related learning the this term that is
often used its called population I may
have used it a couple of times a
population is essentially set of devices
that can participate in learning or in
computation right so yeah so so
essentially clients doesn't necessarily
mean client-server doesn't necessarily
mean the real server these are names
that most of the time you'll use clients
to actually mean clients and and server
to actually mean server but these are
just literals you could use them in any
way you want
right and you can define your own
placements as well slightly more calm
exactly more advanced federated type is
you can actually have a named tuple
right so let's say the server actually
you don't have one value but had two
values right that go in together so you
could do something like that so you know
it could have 32 which has the label a
and another float which is B and that's
that's a named name tuple in general the
this is called a federated tuple the
float example that we saw are called
federated floats so we tend to use you
know federated XYZ if the
the underlying type is XYZ right so if
it's like you know like this is a
federated tuple that's a federated float
so on support right so now that I've
talked about the federated data types we
look at the Fed computation and just to
recap this was the this was the slide
that we this was the scenario that we
tried to do right so you know we sent
threshold to all the bunch of devices
not every device is selected that you
see this one device is not selected so
you send a bunch of devices and then we
got responses back about you know
whether they are maximum temperatures
higher than the threshold or not back
from and then we competed in average
right so that the see now you're gonna
build on using and learning all right
so a federated competition right so the
other thing that was involved here was
this distributed aggregation right so so
if you use the federated types that we
established client says all these
temperatures and you want to compute a
distributed aggregation that gives you
one float federated float that's at the
server then that distributed aggregation
is something that we want to represent
as an operator right because remember
what I mentioned that you know so even
in learning you saw like you know you do
train dot next and essentially
everything that happens in one role of
training happened with that one function
call apparently right
so yeah so if a little drop is
essentially it's a function that you
know one function call that that that
sort of represents the the you know it
represents the whatever happens in a
failure to computation where the inputs
are distributed across multiple clients
and the output is on a server array so
one thing that that is important to
remember here is that this function
calls don't execute it this is actually
when you write it and tff what you are
generating is a deposit basically a
computation plan right so it's you you
it's representations UCL has the
condition of what really should happen
it's really not it doesn't execute right
then right
right so that's why the same say so it's
it's an abstract specification of the of
the communication protocol and not
really actual execution right so if you
if you jumped in the github code I
suggest take a look at the protocol
buffers defying and you'll see how a
competition is defined the competition
has these aspects I mean this fields in
the message body which is what this
thing generates essentially so the
output is essentially one of those
messages that that determine how a faded
competition is to be run so right so now
that we have established what so we need
federated types and we needed operators
right that should give us very good
computation so the first thing in this
particular case is we create this potato
type called readings type and it's the
placement is clients and it's a type of
float32 right so it means that it's a
multi set of clients and and and it's a
32 time so now this is your client side
competition that what happens on a
device right so you want to find in this
particular case average temperature
let's say so you would you'd say that
that my operation is so my so that I
take a federated type and this is what I
want to compute so that annotation at
the FF that federated computation
indicates that this is the specification
of of what will happen at at multiple
clients right so so this is the same
thing this is the representation of the
fact that every client would compute
this average temperature on the settings
right and sorry yeah so so you take a
multi setup of that value the float 32
that is distributed across clients and
that PFF
would then take all those all those
values from the clients and computing a
federated average which is a a standard
Federal Credit computation method and
engineer one value on the server right
so this whole representation about the
protocol about the clients communicating
those temperatures and the server
actually computing an average is is
expressed in that in that in those three
lines of code essentially right so the
first line of code indicates that it
operates on the Federated type that's
reading style that we established and
then it's a normal Python function
declaration and then basically and the
last one is actually a tff tff code that
that says that is you want to compute
Alfred average let's look at the circuit
second example that we that we saw right
which is average sorry which is the
thresholding finding out a fraction of
sensors with readings more than the
threshold so here the things change a
little bit right because we have to send
this threshold out to the so there in
the first example the only operation was
the plants had these temperatures they
send it back to the server the server
computed a federated average that was it
right in this particular case is a
little more interaction right so there
is the the threshold needs to go from
the server to the client the client is
to do this computation you send it back
to the server right so so the first
thing is the broadcast then yeah so now
the server computes that you know
whether it is greater than the threshold
or not and then reports back to the back
to the server right and then the server
does the fader to everything right so
little some more steps involved right so
we already had the readings type right
so we already have that which is
essentially a multi set of float multi
set or
client of the client placement so
essentially it's the sensor values on
different clients now we have a
threshold that we need to pass from the
server to the client straight so we
declared that as as a float32 value as a
federated type and it's the placement of
server once you're done we basically say
so so we declare this as this is the
federate computation it now needs a
reading type and a threshold type and
then basically and you basically get
fraction of a threshold yeah so so is
over float is the local computation that
half thats happening on the device
itself right here which is the threshold
so basically if you look at if we look
at how this is structured so there is
there is the federal-aid computation
which is which is the gate fraction over
threshold that is the overall function
or representation rather and then there
is the TF FTF computation which is which
is a straight-up which which is
basically which indicates that if this
is this is a local operation is
happening on the clients themselves and
which is basically it's just computing
whether that value is over the threshold
or not and then once you have that
essentially you're basically you can now
do the tff operation of federated
averaging so that's is that is the FC
API call which is in the standard
Federated average algo which is
implemented and and then you also have
this other thing called federated map
which is essentially which essentially
takes its it's a function that that gets
the values from the from the from the
different clients right and basically
computes whatever gets reported back
from the clients and basically if you
express that on every client you want to
come
ught is over as float and that's what
you'd return right so the data comes in
so you broadcast the data the threshold
and then basically you compute the is
over as float function right so the key
thing here is there is a separate
declaration that TF FTF computation
which is which basically defines what is
the function that you want to run on the
clients and then there is the the
overall function which is essentially
you know there's a broadcast to the
threshold you run a federated map which
is basically saying okay get the data so
you have the readings and you have the
if the threshold use these two things
and then essentially computer run that
function and then once you get all this
the federal bombings or once you get all
these data back from the client then run
failure to average yeah so this
highlights the the fact that each device
will will perform on its own temperature
reading right and it's not not this is
just this is a local computation like I
mentioned all right showing a bunch of
code but how do I run this right so if I
want to run just this example that we
show we could do something like this
right I did what i'm doing here is i'm
passing if you see i'm passing
ordinarily lists of lists and each list
indicates the outer lists indicate
inputs from a specific client and the
inner list is setting for that client
right and and that's how I can run this
right now obvious question is like
hammer this is not really you did all
this work to represent a federated thing
and then you're driving this locally
right kind of right so so like I
mentioned so we we only support
simulation in local on local machines
now so that indicates that you know you
can basically if you wanted to if you
wrote an algorithm and you want it to
really see how it works then you can
drive this with test data but right but
basically this doesn't really run on
clients yet or devices yet right and but
the other but the thing is all the tff
code annotate annotated code generate a
diploma like a Scylla is a position of
of the distributed communication
protocol and what means what needs to
happen the clan what's going to happen
in the server how they communicate how
does input initial data go from the
server to the client how does
competitions uh from the client what
comes back that whole plan is
essentially was representing the code
above so if we can plug a different
runtime environment this code should be
able to run on on clients on real
devices as well but currently this is
the way to run this and you know yeah
yeah so yeah I mean real devices we
cannot run this on real devices but but
the general concepts of federated
computations are proven so yeah I think
I've mentioned this a few times so
currently the only runtime environment
is the local simulation mode but tff
code is a serialize representation of
the computation right so extending it to
production like environment should not
be that hard right I mean conceptually
I'm not saying implementation I should
not be that hard right it's it's
obviously going to be we have to write
quite a bit of code when I say we I mean
the community of a federated community
has to enable this but architecture Lee
it's cochin trait so it should work yeah
and yeah like I said so it's something
that we really want to enable for at
least some production ligand
otherwise I mean the you know the proof
of the cake is in the eating right so I
mean not being able to run in with
actual devices and actual production
environments is a blocker can be a
blocker for some people but but yeah we
like to we also like to hear from you if
it's if it's really something that will
will will you think it's blocks adoption
or its if this is something that you you
think that we absolutely need right I
would like to hear from you like your
contributions and yeah we we think that
like I mentioned architectural II it's
aligned with adding production like
environments support but yeah I mean so
I didn't mention that I would talk about
a best practice so here it is tff code
is layered as I showed there is
primarily I think of it I think of it as
three layers it could have probably
figure if you think of more but there is
a tff code there is the tensor flow
computation or any computation that
happens on a device and then there's
orchestration right which is the
repeated rounds which is in case of
federated computation we saw that we are
passing in an array but that's
essentially our key station right
how often so in the filter case of
edited learning we saw that we are
running five rounds and we are calling
eval how often you want a valve that's
kind of code that's orchestration right
and suggestion here is that you know
tensorflow really makes it easy for you
Confederated really makes it easy for
you to keep that code modular and son
separate and that makes it the your code
better readable and testable so so best
practice tip there is to keep it modular
such that you know separate those
layers out because there's really
separation of concerns the the the the
bottom three should be able you should
be able to write them separately and and
put them all together and and you know
test them independently yeah I just
highlighting that you know
there is the orchestration this tends to
flow computation that happens on device
and then there is a tensile federated
computations and these things can be
independently tested and this is the
same thing from from the parallel
learning example well you know you are
getting it from the chaos model that's
that's the tensor flow model and then
this averaging process and then this the
the bottom two blobs essentially your
orchestration and yeah we welcome with
contributions everything that you've
seen so far is completely open sourced
the code is and github like I mentioned
please go check out the explore
federated link there are tutorials there
there is API documentation there there's
also a link to the github I think on
above yeah please please please go check
out the code read code try the tutorials
try other scenarios and most importantly
please contribute contribute to to the
repo yeah and and and yes and please let
us know if if this the fact that we we
run on the local simulation environment
how much of that is really impaired in
your adoption and with that yeah so one
last point there is a comic book that
that we published some while back not a
while back a few months back which is
federated with Google calm it's it's an
interesting it's a very interesting
simple way of you know understanding or
credited learning really is and but it's
it's
just not it's just a comic book if you
go there and if you click on learn more
on there you will get a link to the key
papers published across the board not
just by us which sort of help shape
federated learning and favorite
competitions and with that thank you
very much please once again go to
please' flow org slash federated or the
github link and try all the tutorial
check out the code and that's it thank
you